[Music]
thank you
on this edition of The Sky News Daily
podcast we take a look back at some of
the stories which defined 2022 and how
they might shape our lives in future
over five special episodes we will be
looking at politics International
Affairs the royal family climate change
but today we are looking at well a
turbulent year in the economy fueled by
the rising price of oil and of course
skyrocketing inflation and as you can
see if you are watching and if you are
listening you'll hear we're joined by
our economics and data editor Ed Conway
good to see you you too it's been a year
hasn't it it's been a year I mean it's
been extraordinary in in kind of quite a
lot of like short-term and long-term
ways as well it's got like hard to list
all the stuff you know whether it was
what happened in the UK with uh with Liz
truss what happened in Ukraine what's
happening more broadly with kind of
geopolitics you know globalized big
questions over whether globalization is
as we know it is going to proceed now uh
in China with zero covid and of course
with energy so I mean it's
it's not just genuinely hard to know
where to start really well you will get
a break over Christmas so you know but
for now not today
um let's start though with I think one
of the one of the topics which will be
forefronting people's minds right now
because it is cold and people are
starting to have to think about whether
or not to put on the heating the energy
crisis can we be specific as to why we
are in such Dire Straits when it comes
to energy I mean
I mean as ever no because because there
are so many like intertwining issues
here and I think that's part of the
problem is you know when you when you
hear government ministers come on TV
they say it to us a lot it's all about
Putin's War Putin's illegal war and
don't get me wrong that is a massive
part of this okay that's part of the
reason why Energy prices are high and
there's a kind of conventional
explanation that says you've got war in
Ukraine that's pushed up gas prices
enormously we are very reliant on gas in
the UK partly because we have the north
Seas so all of our heating systems you
know they've got gas pumped into them
and then as a result of that we tend to
take a lot of gas from mainly from
Norway actually not much from Russia but
we're still plugged into this European
kind of emergency this European uh
Energy System and as a result of that
anything that happens there
high prices there sources there means it
affects us as well and that's in a sense
the conventional explanation is it
starts with with Putin but the
interesting thing is you know we were
talking about this kind of this time
last year or even before gas prices were
already at a record high long before
this so it's not all about that it's
also you know there are there's a big
build up of of kind of pressures which
have contributed to this as well so
blaming it just all on that and that
that war is kind of a bit
straightforward so so why then was that
this historical kind of increase in in
the course I mean but so so
I and this is I think where it gets
really interesting there's been quite a
long-term under investment in our gas
capacity and I say oh I mean you know
around the world oil and gas companies
they just haven't been kind of exploring
as much they haven't been kind of
pumping getting new Fields as much and
as a result of that even before the
invasion of Ukraine you were seeing this
kind of this disparity between supply
and demand I meant prices were going up
and then obviously Putin goes goes right
into the middle of that at the worst
possible time and has massively exploded
it but as I say it's not just one thing
it's a whole series of things it's kind
of concatenation of different
consequences but all of it feeds into it
into our lives and and that's been one
of the most kind of heart-rending and
disturbing stories and what's disturbing
like from my perspective is we saw this
coming quite a long time ago as I say
you know like more than a year ago we
were talking about high energy even but
even before that weren't we talking
about the lack of you know what's known
as energy Security in the UK that we
were in a really risky I remember you
know a Strategic Defense review talking
about electricity is our energy security
was yeah and it has been for you know
for quite a long time and in some senses
the UK is better place than many parts
of Europe because we have our own you
know gas in the North Sea it's obviously
dwindling at the moment and it's not it
is not enough to provide us and that's
one thing that's worth underlining you
know even if we went out there and
pumped as much as we possibly could we
still wouldn't have enough gas you know
even with the most optimistic
assumptions to supply our massive demand
but then by the same token you know we
are going through this extraordinary
transition at the moment where we're
trying to go you know more Renewables
that is fantastic in many senses because
you know it will be better for the
environment but on the flip side it
could be very expensive because you
still need some sort of backup when
those when the wind is not blowing and
the sun's not shining I mean that's not
that's not going to deny the climate
denial is point that is just a
straightforward thermodynamic
engineering point you need to provide
energy for people as we're all learning
at the moment something you said to me
in one of our earlier podcasts you know
an energy crisis is is an everything
crisis you know that you have high gas
prices making it more expensive to eat
everyone understands that but it also
plays into the cost of Staples and you
use the example of tomatoes which is an
interesting one walk us through it it's
an everything crisis I mean it's it's
such this is it's such a profound Point
by the way Neil because you know I've
covered economics for pretty much two
decades now and and the shocking thing
about it when you think about it is
economics which all of our politicians
depend on it all of the you know the
chancellor the bank of England
everything economic gets into everything
but there's very little consideration
about how much energy matters but then
when you kind of take a step back and
think about the different parts of our
lives and the way that they are you know
fueled by energy so Tomatoes I love it
as an example because when you look at a
cherry tomato you don't think fossil
fuel product no it is a fossil fuel
product in in some senses quite
literally you need fertilizer to help
kind of help it to grow those
fertilizers are made from natural gas
you use methane to get the hydrogen
which in turn gets the nitrogen from the
air through the hoverboard process it's
natural gas when within the fertilizer
all these molecules the oil wants
natural gas you need gas in most of
these greenhouses because most of the
tomatoes that we eat in the UK certainly
in the summer are grown in greenhouses
poly tunnels are actually poly tunnels
in Spain but in the UK mostly it's kind
of enclosed greenhouses I've gone thank
you for correcting me yes you were
saying earlier don't go in too deep into
any kind of wormholes but there is a
tomato Wormhole so so this so the
greenhouse is heated by gas okay so you
need gas but and then the final thing is
you take the kind of extra CO2 that's
pumping out of the out of the those gas
boilers and then you divert that into
the greenhouse it increases the amount
of CO2 in the greenhouse from the
ambient rate in the atmosphere which is
kind of you know for 500 PPM to about
800 PPM and more CO2 means the tomatoes
grow much more quickly
and you see what I mean all of these
different things those are all quite
Divergent ways that we're reliant on
fossil fuels but put them all together
and you can't just easily take the
fossil fuels out we when you eat a
tomato you are eating something which is
quite literally molecules of it come
from fossil fuels and it was heated it
was grown thanks to fossil fuels there
will be a way of doing it without that
but for the time being that's a big part
of our Lives can we just take it back to
to the most pressing concern we're in
Winter and there are genuinely people in
this country making decisions about
whether to eat or whether to heat their
home if people cannot afford to heat
their homes I mean it just you know and
people earning decent enough salaries
there is something fundamentally wrong
with the way things are run I mean is
there an alternative well I think you
know
think about what is the what are the
kind of the hierarchy of needs you know
there's this idea kind of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and somewhere at the
bottom a kind of shelter heat and food
well you know shelter that's that's
again an issue that there is a kind of
growing uh ranks of the the homeless in
this country
um but but Heating
we've never really had to contend with
anything like this in terms of the
increase the amount of our everyday
spending that has had to be given over
to Heating and that's something again
that we've tried to reflect in our
coverage over the years showing kind of
charts of this and as I say that was the
scary thing for me we were doing these
charts back in I think you know at the
start of the Year saying with gas prices
where they are at the moment even before
that Invasion here's what chunk it takes
out of your out of your spending and
that chunk has kind of got bigger and
bigger and the upshot being that yeah it
is it is it is terrifying it's been
absolutely terrifying and the government
has intervened
um the the other thing though just to
mention you know we're talking about
tomatoes well because they are fossil
fuel products well because they're made
from gas those prices have gone up as
well so if you're kind of looking at
your spending and wondering why are food
prices so high it's part of the same
thing this is why an energy crisis isn't
everything crisis because it pushes up
the cost of absolutely everything
because every form of economic activity
is a form of energy transmission
transfer you know your trans turning
energy whether it's physical energy or
whether it's kind of you know the energy
that's going into a transport system or
into your computer so you're turning
that into economic output and so as a
result we are all worse off because the
cost of that energy has gone up and
sorry to go back to your kind of initial
question
that I I kind of Wonder this is like an
idle thought at times like this you know
what is the government for well to some
extent I think the government is for
trying to help ensure that we all have
you know an ability to have the standard
of living that we would all like and if
Energy prices suddenly go up from a kind
of you know relatively low level to an
unaffordable level then it's certainly
the government's role to to try to kind
of ensure that people are able to deal
with that because it's so pervasive and
that is what they've done but there's a
question mark as to whether that's
something that they should be doing
permanently I don't know here's the
thing I mean right now it isn't just you
know the the cost of energy that is
going up it is it is genuinely the cost
of pretty much it pretty much everything
just just explain it because it cannot
simply be down to inflation no well I
mean you know it's so so partly you've
got this energy story and partly you've
got the world kind of rebounding after
covert 19. that's it yes and so as a
result of that you know we've seen and
it it preceded this late latest crisis
but it's it's blended into it you've
seen the prices of things like well
semiconductors going up so computer
chips was was a massive issue at the
start of the year and the interesting
thing with all these kind of Supply
shocks is you have a massive shortage
and we had that shortage kind of you
know about a year ago and that's meant
that it's been very difficult to buy
cars or buy consoles for Christmas
presents you know PlayStation 5s and
things are still quite short in Supply
but then the market responds and you've
had all these companies kind of like
suddenly churning out loads more chips
and now we've got a kind of potential
semiconductor glut and so the prices of
those things is kind of going down and
you know it's wonderful because the
market is actually responding but there
is a kind of a bigger more secular wave
so when I say secular I mean kind of
like running over many years and that is
that if we are going to achieve all of
the kind of big grand net zero goals
that the government and this government
and other governments have then you need
an enormous amount of kind of building
construction mining all of the Lots and
it's not nice you've been no you've seen
it's well it's it's mining is is a
pretty brutal activity you need to kind
of explode enormous chunks out of the
ground and kind of grind them up and
then you know blend them in acid and do
all of these other things to Simply put
you're not desperately in the pursuit of
the greatest environmental goal Net Zero
we are indulging in some fairly
unenvironmentally you know
environmentally unfriendly practices
yeah Mining and kind of whether it's
lithium extractions so lithium being
being one of the most important um
chemicals that we put into batteries or
copper and people kind of understate the
extent to which copper is is is so
important for everything you know all of
our the reason you're able to listen to
this podcast is because of copper the
reason that we all have electricity is
because of copper the biggest probably
the single biggest economic leap that
the world has had saved for maybe you
know the moment where we all kind of
worked out how to do agriculture was
when electricity came along and suddenly
changed everyone's lives in this way
that again
it's it's difficult to get your head run
so we need to get maybe double the
amount of copper that we currently are
getting out of the ground every year
into the future just to satisfy the need
for more wind turbines for more
electrification for more electric cars
and the the kind of upshot of all of
this
is
that's how we get to Net Zero and there
is a kind of you know there is a
dirtiness to getting there but the point
is you know when you look beyond that
dirtiness then you kind of have a future
where you're not emitting as much carbon
and that's that's a good thing but the I
think what people have kind of look not
really quite kind of Taken account of is
the fact that there's a kind of Hump of
what we get to the kind of Net Zero of
needing to do an extraordinary amount of
exploitation not necessarily fossil
fuels and the good news is you're with
this copy you're getting under the
ground you're building stuff with it
rather than burning it which is what you
do with oil and coal at the moment and
you can recycle a lot of it however you
just need so much more of it now and I I
spent you know I went to Chile where
they have the world's biggest copper
mines uh they have the world's biggest
reserves of lithium as well and seeing
their stuff in person
it is enormous it is just enormous the
scale of these lithium ponds that
they're kind of extracting lithium from
the depth of this mine that I went to
and it's a place called chuki kamata in
Chile it is mind-blowing and because
it's out of sight you know way off in
the Chilean desert you don't really
think about it that much but golly I
mean we need multiples more of these
massive holes in the ground if we're
going to get to Net Zero and a final
thought on that
funnily enough the grades of copper you
get okay here's a way of thinking about
it the greater copper you get in Chile
are not dissimilar actually a little bit
worse than some of the grades that are
still in the ground in Cornwall
okay so technically speaking if we
wanted to be self-sufficient in Copper
we could go and blast massive holes in
the ground in corn in Cornwall is that
likely
well I mean you know I'll ask ask people
with Holiday Homes down in Cornwall but
that's the point that's that is the the
issue we're wrestling with now it's it's
dirty and it involves a lot of kind of
you know planning constraints to to get
the stuff out the ground I I think the
residents of Cornwall might need a deep
breath I think you should take a deep
breath as well because after the break
we will be talking mortgages see in a
sec
foreign
welcome back to this special edition of
The Sky News Daily podcast our data and
economics editor at Conway is still here
and you know I've warned people to
perhaps have a deep breath um before
listening to this part of the podcast
mortgages I mean it is grim out there at
the moment isn't it if you have a
mortgage yeah yeah uh of course and we
will talk about it well exactly
um but it's one of I think one this has
been one of the big misconceptions that
we've had to kind of wrestle with this
year is that a lot of people kind of
blithely thinking so we started the year
with interest rates kind of at 0.25 so
the bank of England just raised them for
0.1 percent
um
and they're at 0.25 and back then a lot
of you know when you looked at the
market expectations so out there in the
money markets even you know right now
there are people kind of constantly
betting on what the interest rates are
likely to be in the future okay so you
get these money markets which are kind
of looking and you can look through that
and kind of draw up a line of where they
expect rates to go and that's kind of
what your mortgage your fixed rate
mortgage your refixing is based off
those rates are going to swap rates uh
go up in a certain line at the start of
the year or early on in the year people
thought maybe interest rates would get
up to maybe 1.5 percent the bank of
England interest rates
then you obviously had the Tory
leadership campaign you had the war in
Ukraine you had a lot of kind of
exogenous factors as economists would
call them stuff happening elsewhere but
also kind of endogenous issues within
the UK so our own political problems
yeah quasi-quarting had a hand in it
yeah so quasi quasi was was a big part
of it but but also even in the run-up to
Liz truss's election as as prime
minister you could see those rates going
up because people were saying oh
inflation's high but also this
government was going to spend more and
when they're going to spend more we're
going to kind of increase those
expectations so then quasi quatane comes
in then you have the the catastrophic
mini budget those rates so the expected
rates for mortgages you're up from at
that point maybe four and a half percent
to
6.34 for interest rates next year and
this is where I think one of those
misconceptions come in a lot of people
looked at that and remembered the 70s
and they remember the 70s and they
remember the 80s when it went up to
double-digit levels and it's like well I
lived through that why is everyone
complaining you know so why have they
got that so badly wrong what is the
misconception because again I've had
people approach me in the street saying
that you know people these days don't
know what so you know don't know they're
born you know I had to deal with 13 14
15. yeah the snowflakes aren't they so
but the reality is
um I mean it is true rates
up at six percent or lower than they
than they would were back in the kind of
the 80s and 70s
um however the amounts of debt that the
average mortgage holder has is also
much higher so if you think about an
interest rate you know five percent of a
big amount is potentially even bigger
than 10 percent of a relatively small
amount so there's that the amount of
debt that we've got is is larger the
size of our incomes relative to our
mortgages is also not as high as it was
back in the 70s and the in the 80s
because we're not getting kind of well
off at the same rate and so that key
thing is our ability to service the debt
okay that is where we run into potential
potentially people going into kind of
negative equity facing major problems
about servicing their mortgages and the
issue is that at six percent we are
hitting the same kind of levels for
people getting new mortgages than you
were back in
1989 90 the very worst point in British
history for mortgage pain but here's the
issue though Neil not
back then I think more people had
mortgages right now actually there's
fewer people with mortgages partly
because you've got a lot of people
generally kind of older better off
people who've already paid off their
mortgage and so the degree of pain this
is the interesting thing when you ask
the bank of England about this they're
like well yeah it'd be awful be really
awful for those people who do have
mortgages younger people mostly really
kind of hard-pressed but for the economy
as a whole maybe it would be okay and
they have to look at the economy as a
whole so that's what I think is going to
be interesting I say interesting
unfortunately in italics because it's
you know it must be quite scary yeah
just a word then I mean are we now going
to see a generation I mean I'm lucky
enough to have a mortgage and it's been
a pain over the years don't get me wrong
but I'm very very lucky to have had it
and I couldn't have got it without some
help from my mom and dad that is not
available to many many people these days
are we basically seeing a generation
that will be unable to get a property
get up get a fruit on the property
ladder I mean if they're renting at the
moment dear dear goodness that in and of
itself is incredibly expensive I think
we're already in that I think we've been
in that for a while I think we've been
in that for a while I think it's I think
there's a kind of you know a parasite
between people who are able to and who
aren't able to get hold of the financing
for mortgages of the deposits for
mortgages as well and that is it's it's
so troubling but it's not a new issue
and I think this this exacerbates it
um but unfortunately we've had this for
a long time and you know
I don't know if there's any kind of
particularly straightforward explanation
kind of resolutions to it build houses
well build houses is part of it but but
you know
actually there are parts of it that
the build houses one is part of it but a
few years ago you know we made a piece
which pointed out that when you talk
about the housing crisis actually
there's various different housing crises
in the UK there's parts of the country
where definitely more houses would be
helpful but there's also parts of the
country where
there's too many houses and they're
actually pulling houses down you know
actually parts of Scotland yes and uh
some parts of the Northeast as well and
so there's
there's no straightforward kind of
solution to this
and the upshot and the problem is that
you know if you're renting at the moment
as well sorry to just add some extra
kind of bad news but if you're renting
right now rents are going up really fast
as well
the difficulty is it's a distributional
thing a lot of people have done very
very well out of housing over the course
of the last two decades or even longer
very well indeed and they paid off their
mortgages and they've had a net increase
in their wealth and younger people just
haven't been able to kind of get on that
kind of ladder and on that roller
coaster as easily it's terrible isn't it
and you and you really you really do
feel for them and I do want you to cast
your eye you know away from 2022 and and
into 2023 and I'm not asking you to
promise me that things are definitely
going to get better but if you could
gently suggest that I'd really they will
get but I mean but they will get better
in as much as we've already we've
possibly passed the peak for inflation
okay and we've probably passed the peak
of the bank of England's the rate at
which they're increasing interest rates
okay so they've slowed down the rates at
which they're increasing interest rates
and as inflation starts to go down then
people might you know should hopefully
feel a bit better off the recession
might not necessarily be all that deep
the concern though is just that although
it's not a kind of a specially deep
recession it's very felt in particular
households pockets and we're all feeling
it in terms of the energy squeeze but
these things you know it's not Grim it's
not Grim forever and you know there is
an enormous opportunity here where the
world is going to be potentially
building all these new technologies you
know we've heard recently about nuclear
fusion we've heard about all of these
different ways that we are kind of
making the world a better cleaner faster
place
but that takes some work and so it takes
a lot of building and it takes a lot of
kind of mining to get there Ed do you
know what we'll leave it there before
you depress me any further Ed Conway
cracking stuff as always and of course a
number of the topics that Ed and I have
been discussing we've covered in far
greater depth on other episodes of The
Sky News Daily you can find those where
you found this one and you can also
listen to our other reviews of the
everything from politics of course to
the royal family whatever you're
listening to this uh Ed everyone else
thanks very much for being with us
[Music]